Aaron Carter has been arrested he had  learned the 29 year old singer was  arrested in Haversham County Georgia on  Saturday night a spokesperson for the  Haversham County Sheriff's Office tells  ET Aaron was arrested on charges of DUI  refusal possession of less than one  ounce of marijuana and drug related  objects the former child star was set to  perform a concert with Flo Rida in  Kansas City Missouri on Saturday and had  a scheduled appearance on Sunday  Aaron's team took to social media to  tweet on his behalf he would not be  making it to the show due to quote  transportation issues he has reached out  to Carter's rep for comment